so let's talk about what I would
consider a little bit of a downer topic
and then that's a Financial Risk and
I'll just tell you about the things that
I worry about uh first and foremost what
happens if I lose my job and maybe it's
a bad economy and I have trouble getting
a job or I have trouble getting a job
that's at the same level of income what
will I and my family then do to support
ourselves how will we pay our mortgage
how will we pay down other things that
we need how will we pay for food Etc and
in general that type of risk I think the
best way to mitigate it if it happens is
to have a nest egg to start saving money
so that you can have several months to
live off of it ideally so that you have
time to find a job and you have a little
bit of a cushion if you need to downsize
it allows you to transition there
another thing that I worry about is well
what if hap something not losing my job
but what if I get injured in some way
what if I fall a sick or what if someone
I care care about Falls sick and they
need help with their with their medical
bills that could be a very very very
significant expense now things like
illness or if I were to somehow get
disabled somehow so I can't work there
are sometimes insurances for that
especially things like disability
insurance but once again probably the
the best option you might be able to get
some insurance but also to have a nest
tag to save some money so that in case
something were to happen where the
income gets interrupted either for
yourself or your partner or others that
you have a cushion to support you in
that
but there are many many other types of
risk as I said this is going to be a
downer conversation there's the risk of
death and I know what some of you all
are thinking I thought this a little bit
when I was young well once I die
um
you know why why would I worry about
finances at that point well there might
be people who are dependent on you that
you care about that you want to still be
in a good situation and you know for I
for example once I had kids I completely
understood the point of life insurance
and so one you can once again save money
saving money is usually a good solution
for many many many many things but on
top of that you know I just recently uh
extended my life insurance policy so
that if anything were to happen to me
obviously our income would go away my
wife might need more help uh help being
able to raise the family so I have a
life insurance policy to help in in that
situation so if I were to pass the
insurance company would pay my family
money to to help them out and I will say
that even savings and investment come
with some Financial Risk you can lose
money on your savings or or especially
on your investment if the stock market
can go down you might have a lot of your
savings in fact most people do have a
lot of their wealth in their house and
housing prices can sometimes go down so
that is a real risk and even with
savings if there's a lot of inflation
and your money's just sitting in the
bank getting less interest than the
amount of inflation that there's there
that an actual ability to buy things
with that money it could be going down
so there's even a risk there
so generally speaking uh it you know I
don't want you to get too anxious or
paranoid about Financial Risk but it's
healthy to be aware of all of the risks
that might be out there I didn't list
all of them and the general mechanisms
you're going to have to uh make sure
that that you have some cushion in life
is ideally saving and then you might be
able to get insurance for certain things
and there's other types of risk I mean
the more I think about it unfortunately
it's easy to think of other words
there's liability if you got into a car
accident and and you're in the wrong and
someone sues you you could owe a lot of
money uh to them and once again there's
insurances for that liability insurance
but if if it goes above and beyond the
the insurance cap or if you didn't have
insurance it's people could go bankrupt
over a liability or owing someone you
could have property damage let's say
your house gets struck by lightning or
burns down and you didn't have insurance
on it well that can really hurt you
financially so once again uh think about
the risks don't uh don't have too many
sleepless nights about them I try not to
uh but the the best thing is to just
think about where you can be insured uh
and and it's reasonable think about
where you can save money and then also
be very careful uh so that some of these
risks don't have happen to you like uh
you know take precautions so that
hopefully you don't have liability or
take precaution so that someone can't
steal your identity or steal your credit
card and take money from you that's
another Financial Risk and and that one
is well there is some identity theft
Insurance and things like that but that
you know the best the best thing to do
is just to be careful so be careful out
there save your money and you might want
to think about insurance where
appropriate